personne match de gala psg 3 diffusée en
clair en direct sur ces huit heures on
est obligé de refaire le jeu des
maillots devant le par le principe il
est simple on prend que les yeux de
supporters parisiens on demande dans fil
en moins de 30 secondes le maillot tu
démarres s'il réussit il gagne le
maillot qui vaut dans les 1200 balle non
mais en réalité au la remplacer par un
om regardez c'est la nouvelle situation
ternit plus drôle
est il à faire je suis content là te
plait vraiment j'ai mis non
c'était facile ouais ça va ça va borloo
veut être un peu de difficultés 6e parlé
ici c'est paris
oh non non non franchement ça s'est
terminé un cercueil et là on à couillet
allez par est allé monsieur ici ça
m